I feel like I'm drinking the kool-aid
right now but this is like genuinely
dream come true kind of experience holy
[ __ ] after all if you find a mask it
fits you never need to take it off I'm
tomorrow we here at gamescom 2015 I'm at
a loss of just played the batman arkham
vr demo and I thought it was incredible
but I've never seen you so happy I was
all up in my feelings I was a child
again I've seen a lot of people talking
about this and like showering it with
praise not like year probably it's
probably all right it's just bad manners
name but a holy moly I won't explain
what happens because I've part of the
experience but I felt like a child again
and I was realizing things and dreams
that I've had since I was a young boy
like if you are a Batman kind like this
is sounds like going over the top but
I'm gonna buy a place they should be off
of this oh my god I've always wanted my
own bed sooo finally I just want to
stroke it before I put it on and based
on what we spoke to a couple people from
rock steady and it seems like they're
developing it into a quite a substantial
thing that's what I got the feeling my
favorite thing
like a Gwent thing right it's like a
small passion project and it gets bigger
and bigger more people get involved and
that's basically the exactly what's
happened with that might be a job it is
these special like I there's two parts
of it I want to expend what happens one
is I think becoming the Batman is
probably enough to kind of sell it and
the next part is realizing the detective
part of being about nothing like you
know the vin arkham city where you're on
the rooftop and you're dressed as Bruce
Wayne and the balance the Batmobile the
battling but we're drops off the bus
when you do but it's like yet it's
imaginal living that like just that
feelings through like just experiencing
it properly and in the Arkham games
pressing the button to become the Batman
was quite empowering take that to the
extreme like and the feeling and just
ratchet up the feeling he felt in that
moment into like just the very very
limit and like I would like I said I was
a kid again my legs were shaking a bit
and I was like just a goofball I cool
this is like you know how they are
concerns that keep saying be the Batman
this is the most betta Batman moment
I've ever had it's the environment as
well everything there is so much
meticulous attention to detail there's
some amazing music cues as well that
didn't really add to the emotion of the
moment as well which I love the people
interact with our just realistic yeah
it's just it's incredible like you've
never liked we're done where I've never
done this before like it's one of the
few PlayStation VR experiences that I've
had and this is the one that really sold
me on it like I realized that my love of
Batman is going the extra mile to sell
me on it but like speaking to your
people from rock steady they kept
mentioning how this was an opportunity
to focus on something which they
traditionally have shunned away which is
the investigation stuff they're saying a
lot of the right things like they're
looking to hush as an inspiration which
is kind of like an a constant feeling of
mystery and involving loads of like
villains and recognized organ and it's
one of the best it's you know that one
of the must-read Batman novels so like I
think I think that they're saying all
the right things I think they can
deliver in a rock steady for the most
part I haven't done us wrong other than
technical stuff but like the games are
good but yeah I'm excited in a way that
I'm gonna stay one of games coming I'm
already like hyper mode oh oh my god
I just need to sit down for a little
while well well how many comes out as we
SPR launch title when it comes out later
this year for more on Burma and make
sure you stay tuned to gamespot duck
phone height spot.com I'm so happy
you